smile and the world smiles with you how
early in life do we learn this age-old
truth
experts tell us that the smile a baby's
first smile is his first conscious act
in trying to adjust to a brand new world
world as the months speed by and we
reached the ripe old age of 2 we find
that smiles continue to pay dividends it
is an effective way to win friends and
influence people
glorious carefree days of growing up
exciting new experiences smiles and
Happiness which should be the
inheritance of every child everywhere
when boy meets girl and knows it first
time it is usually a smile that bridges
the gulf of self-consciousness and
youthful timidity
[Music]
[Applause]
and so on into college going places and
doing things is a matter of help and
energy and the best bids usually go to
those with healthy charming smile the
smile is an asset in business - in these
days of stiff competition with hustle
and bustle and jangled nerves very often
the smile win opens doors creates
important friendships down through the
years smile should continue winning
confidence gaining loyalties creating
happiness natural smiles
springing from buoyant health and even
on into the sunset of life there are
smiling recollections of old friends old
memories happy things which have gone
before and the quiet happiness that
comes from sharing Joy's with people of
the future yes it can truly be said that
a healthful charming smile is important
to us
day after day all through our lives and
so let us examine this smile to see what
it is that makes a smile effective often
one doesn't realize it but good teeth
are really the backbone of almost every
attractive smile if the teeth are strong
and regularly spaced and clean then the
smile is right but if they are not then
somehow the smile is wrong and your
whole personality is changed medical and
dental history show that the beginning
of this perfect smile was started during
the first months of pregnancy and lucky
indeed is the child who picks the mother
who visits her physician and her dentist
during these early month by paying these
early visits and by following advice
given them the expectant mother can
build strong bones and teeth or her
child she can protect herself - from the
old adage now disproved for every child
of two
[Music]
what a happy event it is when baby's
first tooth arrives and it usually does
when the baby is between four and seven
months old another important event is
your child's first clip this occasion
should be when about we roll and here in
your dentist office you will find a very
different situation than existed 20 or
30 years ago dentists today treat the
child with a much keener knowledge of
child psychology than was possible in
the past very often these early visits
are a method of cleaning and inspection
but should important effects be found
they can be corrected more easily now
than if they are allowed to wait caring
for these deciduous or baby or so-called
temporary teeth is important because
they are not entirely replaced until the
child is 12 years old
which is about one-fifth of his normal
lifespan moreover these first teeth lay
the foundation for his permanent teeth
which should last for the rest of his
life as the result of these early Vivat
a child soon accepts the idea of good
dental health and forms the pattern of
regular visits which will be invaluable
to him under the friendly guidance of
his dentist he learns the how and why of
mouth cleanliness which when started
early enough becomes as automatic as do
many other essential health habits
periodic inspection by the dentist and
daily attention at home to these so
called temporary or baby teeth lay a
firm groundwork for good dental health
throughout his life when your child is
about 6 we come to another milestone
this is about the time when the first
permanent tooth erupts while this tooth
is called the 6-year molar or the first
permanent molar start looking for it
when your child is about 5 even before
he starts losing his temporary teeth if
you want to find it 6 is your cue start
from the front and count the teeth
around to either side the sixth is the
6-year molar or first permanent molars
on either side and this first permanent
tooth acts as the keystone for the whole
dental arch this then is another time
when it is important to have your child
under the periodic inspection and care
your dentist good dental health is
usually the result of a three-way
partnership in which mother plays a
daily role of specialists here under the
guise of preparing something good to eat
mother and little sue are really
collecting the vitamins and mineral
elements necessary to build growing
bodies strong and straight
supplying fuel for energetic expanding
muscles supplying calcium for strong
bones and for sturdy sparkling teeth so
far seeing is the alchemy of nature that
out of a regular supply of nature's
simplest foods like fruit vegetables and
milk can be found the necessary elements
to help bodies grow and to protect those
already grown here is a refrigerator
brim full of health giving foods notice
they are natural simple foods obtainable
almost anywhere and they are not
expensive good dental health usually
goes with all-round good health and a
simple protective diet will do much to
ensure both for your whole family
this protective diet calls for a quart
of milk two fresh vegetables one
preferably raw and leafy two fresh
fruits an egg and a serving of whole
grain cereal as the skeleton for every
day's meal these common foods if eaten
regularly together with a milk fortified
with vitamin B or cod liver oil is
recommended will furnish the vital
necessities for sound teeth and buoyant
health special attention to food and
regular eating habits is the general
rule for very young children and babies
yet growth is something that continues
long after Bill puts on long pants a
symbol to him that he has grown up Mary
too may be sure she's a young lady when
she's grown-up enough to wear a long
party dress but actually during these
adjusting periods of adolescence the
vitamins and mineral elements of the
protective diet are just as necessary
for them as when they were babies all
through life a good working plan is to
choose first those foods which you need
most and then
eat whatever else you may like but look
at this dinner which is getting ready to
go on the table
nature's simplest foods can be prepared
so attractively and the menus can be
varied so greatly that you and your
whole family will enjoy them not for
just their vitamins not for their
minerals nor for their calcium nor for
any of their health building properties
but because they are really and truly
good to eat milk plays its part in this
enjoyable eating the day's quota of a
quart of milk adds appetite appeal to
vegetables in creamy sauces and savory
suits in custards and dozens of other
tempting foods mother will be proud to
serve fresh sweet cream or milk is the
perfect topping for fresh juicy berries
for fall of the whole grill then of
course Erised milk is a simple enjoyable
way for each member of the family to get
his quota
of this natural healthful food business
every day American manhood stems back to
American childhood the children of today
are the men and women of the future may
they go far and may they go smile cause
of the sound body's alert minds and
courageous energy which their parents
have helped them build behind the smile
[Music]